ja und was die anderen länder uns beim
impfen gerade voraus haben das hat einer
an seinem eigenen leib erfahren nämlich
peter wilke aus mülheim an der ruhr es
eher mehr zugeschaltet ich grüße sie
herr wilke brüssel haben sie erwecke in
mülheim an der ruhr in ihrer heimat den
schon einen impftermin bekommen nein
dafür bekommen haben karten für diese
machten okay immerhin hilft aber beim
impfen überhaupt nicht sie werden ja
vermutlich so langsam an der reihe wann
rechnen sie damit dass sie in mülheim an
der ruhr geimpft werden können wenn
jetzt so genannte zweite stoffe los mit
den impfungen und ich habe keine ahnung
oder scheinen jetzt nicht jeder offizier
kann ich nichts gehört und nichts
spricht wo also auch keine nachricht vom
arzt vom gesundheitsamt jahren ist die
hauswände und setzte sich letztlich kein
jetzt haben sie eine besondere
überraschung bekommen erzählen sie mal
die kamen nämlich aus großbritannien
richtig ausgerichtet auf russland so
viele schwierigkeiten jedoch tatsächlich
gibt aber in diesem fall nicht die haben
mich zum impftermin eingeladen ich durch
den mieter in welchen klar ich könnte
und das wirst du kurzfristig passieren
und ich kann mehr verbreiten ein
bisschen gaga dass man sparen wenn mich
natürlich ebenfalls eine einladung
bekommen hat der wird jetzt zum
sonntagabend im kino an
das heißt dann noch stehen durch 44
stunden und tage die woche also bis hin
ungewöhnliche überraschungen positive
überraschungen sie sitzen zu hause in
mülheim warten auf ihren impftermin
hören überhaupt nichts von den behörden
nicht von den ärzten habe noch keine
ahnung wann das los gehen soll und dann
plötzlich auf dem handy kommt die sms
aus großbritannien sie können zu uns
kommen absolut richtig was machen sie
damit jetzt gehen sie gehen sie rüber
auf die insel lassen sich wirklich da
impfen nehmen sie den termin war
im moment haben und erkennen
entscheidung positive porsche müsste es
noch zu früh ist jeder anderen jetzt
gescheitert wir haben wohl geantwortet
durch die soko christlich wird mich drin
dafür zu melden was sagt das über uns
hier in deutschland aus wenn sie in ihre
heimat im ruhrgebiet sitzen und die
briten schneller sind in der sms total
problemlos aufs handy schicken und wir
wissen noch nichtmal wann das sie
losgehen soll für sie ja ich finde es
bedrückend muss ich wirklich sagen in
der küche mit einem jahr mit den dingen
befasst sich scheint das nicht zu
funktionieren
jetzt wird eine horrormeldung ich lieb
dich schon gar nicht mehr
ich möchte nur ganz gerne die impfungen
zu den kritischen
heute würde ich gedacht 70 jahre alt und
durch laut hb nicht ich wünsche ihnen
alles gute ich an ihrer stelle würde
glaube ich wenn es irgendwie logistisch
geht erst recht mit der familie dort in
großbritannien den impftermin wahrnehmen
denn wer weiß ob das in nächster zeit
hier in deutschland tatsächlich klappt
mit den ganzen verzögerungen herreweghe
alles gute für sie und toi toi toi für
die baldige impfung können wir brauchen
dankeschön